the foundation for positively kids broke  ground on the center for special needs  children today the 60-bed facility will  take care of those with long-term and  complex medical conditions there's also  an opportunity for some outpatient  therapy the ceo of the foundation says  it will be more beneficial to finally  have this facility in our state  obviously it benefits the children  who've been sent out of state for care  but it certainly benefits the families  you've got a family that has to drive to  california arizona utah to see their  child so there's a psychological effect  also in addition to the medical care  that needs to take place  positively kids has six programs  including two medical clinics here in  southern nevada providing critical  health care to children and families